today's guest is a young man who a nana
and an adult man who has long been a
confidante and inspiration and a friend
to me in this business he gave me my
first job on television as a host of his
hit show deal with it that was a hit but
also was not a hit and we we didn't get
any more episodes but but still we did
good he's created countless amazing
projects over the years from Bobby's
world to the voice in gremlins he's a
judge on America's Got Talent
he's an amazing family man he really has
been someone special in my life he's got
a new special on Showtime
it's his first in 20 years and his new
hit show Deal or No Deal is back on CNBC
ladies and gentlemen my friend mr. Howie
Mandel
[Music]
oh yeah you look different
ten cow mango Clementine yeah which
officer is like one of the candles which
is also a girl likes to date in middle
school - mango yeah lady you know Wow
so she bruised easily though she bruised
easily and yeah I just saw her fall on
the playground 100k cuz thank God you
know right because what you think you're
bruising easily could be and also
bruising easily sounds like a famous
fighter wasn't it
bruising easily yeah that's a good name
for a fighter I guess yeah
I can set your code somewhere Lee Wow
there's candles and then look at me no
and you know what this is I love what
you've done with the place
howie mandel I'm the FDR biopic right
here you think you could play FDR do I
look like FDR to you at the you have to
put on some weight I know you know to be
honest with you I'm Canadian you know
that oh yeah so I'm not I know who FDR
was but I'm not really familiar with the
this look being close to all because of
the wheelchair
yeah I'm just that we all go I see with
that yeah I could say I got it now
thanks for coming Howie yeah yeah the
reason I put my coat on my lap is
because when I do podcasts I pee really
well yeah especially if I'm drinking oh
we get you fully hydrated too and that's
why we get that plant right there too if
you want to drop a look at another
dueling and descent everything's about
smells we got a lot going on in here you
do yeah okay and we got Howie Mandel in
here today dude thanks for coming man
thanks for having me huge fan
I'm H fan you Anna you as a human as a
comic and also in your love of
oh thanks brother or guinea pig both we
should sell them no I know
oh yes certs you told me you so you had
concerts you had truckloads yeah
fifty to a truck that's the legal amount
there is a number oh yeah fifty no
matter how big the truck is mm-hmm oh
now I don't know about that but fifty
was at was that enforced to oblige did
anybody come and count your hamster's
you got fifty two here man lost a lot
need you to get her to leave two on the
roadside here brother you know you have
to send two on their way um no one
stayed is that a line that's in uh
Louisiana I think California how many
hamsters are you allowed in the truck
probably one and it better have a in it
better it's probably have to be a
service hamster you know which is not
crazy now there was a woman I just saw a
couple weeks ago that took a service
squirrel on a flight that's and she's
really upset that they took her service
squirrel
what calming effect could a squirrel
have yeah I get a hamster hamsters nice
but it but a squirrel is not a calming
are they rodent is a squirrel rodent oh
dude look I mean don't say it to their
face but yeah I uh I'm always wondering
because you ever have a squirrel run in
front of your car oh yeah but it gets
like halfway across the street and then
it's like oh I forgot something and a
runny nose no I don't need that and then
it runs back it does it's it's squirrels
are the probably the worst decision
makers in the rodent world I feel
oh it's lower than xiety no its mother
nature's Tourette's I mean it's the law
you know it's Mother Nature's anxiety I
feel like it's just like a you know it's
like an embodiment of anxiety they seem
like anxiety don't they they really do
and they run back and forth yet they
really focused on one food group just
nuts
yeah they just gather nuts yeah and it's
not they made a decision there but
that's like the only decision they made
they're going up to tree they're down
the tree they're up the thing the cross
the cross the road back across the road
back across they can't make any decision
but
but nuts dinner like I'll say to my wife
where do you want to go she goes I can't
decide you decide I go why can't you be
like a [ __ ] squirrel just make a
decision when it comes to food just nuts
but my wife will go straight across the
road without right you ever turning back
my wife is so much to me I love her more
than squirrels really I do
oh I do I could see that how was your
wife doing good I think she's fantastic
yeah I think she's fantastic 40 years
Wow
forty years not old that's how long
we've been married yeah 40 years and did
it feel do you still feel like that'll
be a good shot your your partner in
crime here your producer are you taking
an iphone shot of us yeah from above oh
yeah like he couldn't hold that higher I
said we're in the same room he stood up
to take the picture is this an edict
from you that's how he does it no no you
you said I only look good from 90
degrees above us that's how we look but
I mean he's sitting above us but he
stood up I'm saying I don't mind that
there was a picture taken but he's
taking it from the ceiling down he wants
to see it all yeah normally I get a
better angle but you brought your
entourage here today so much room you
did it's not an entourage these are your
friends are these people hey rich are
these people are filming you all the
time now Ali what's going on I thought
they're filming you now Mike Bonner said
they were here to film you today Mike
binder phoned me to tell me that you're
a big part of his documentary do you
mind I hear you're doing Theo's do you
mind if the cameras here oh wow yes is
your it's weird to have an entourage
that you're not even claiming yeah it's
an entourage dude it's not mine it's not
mine so yeah so it's that's why maybe I
entourage is French for people who
wander in for no reason at all yeah
peeping are you here for Theo are you
here for me equally right but Mike you
work with Mike binder yeah Mike binder
is doing a documentary on the comedy
store where we both work right and and
so in your big part of the documentary
you're a big part of the community
i sat down with him did you sit down
with me and I sat down with him so we
did the exact same thing so he's the one
that called me and said I hear you're
doing Theo's podcast were Theo's a big
part of this do you mind if we have
cameras I go it's up to Theo this is
Theo's podcast it's Theo's office
this is Theo's entourage I got one guy
named rich there that's with me oh I've
seen you have the whole camera crew you
got a pictures from above I don't know
them either okay well what's your names
guys that's Bert Bert what other guy the
two guys named Bert okay it's like Bert
and Ernie but there's no Ernie just Bert
it's Bert and Bert it's a twins dude and
I think twins if you're twins
fight it to the death figure it out you
know what I'm saying really the fact
that there's two to it that they're yeah
figure it out
what do you mean what are you saying I
would I would love to have another no
really dude if you if they had to ally
Mandel's you wouldn't be able to stand
it I would love it no we're not gonna do
multitasking no he's not gonna do what
you wanted to do I'm from Canada and in
Canada they have twins there while the
legal rule is you can only have up to 50
Howie Mandel's in a car I think that's
the law I think that that's the law get
see that dude
well if there's ever more than one
Mandel I think the earth will stop
spinning wouldn't you love to just [ __ ]
around with somebody that like just have
a good with somebody who is identical to
you you don't think that would be like
the ultimate prop for life I mean if you
could now seriously if you could can you
get them to do what you wanted to do but
I have a feeling the way though that
everything's even in the world kind of
in mother nature and stuff I think that
they would they become this the dark you
know they'd be the dark side do you know
any identical twins oh yeah dude it
wasn't dark where I'm from the wasn't
super welcome in really oh dude it's
it's basically just you know it's
familial witchcraft really when you
think about it when you think there's
somebody's gonna look just like you
they're gonna eat like you finish your
sentences oh I wanted I wanted I wanted
to be a twin I wanted to make twin you
know how much time
spent with a I used to try to slice my
sperm in half he didn't really I tried I
didn't know how I didn't know how these
things came to be so I just wanted I
would like to be a twin we have twins
I think twins are cool well you guys
have any more children you have three
children right now I have three children
and now the children are having children
yeah so my daughter who had her second
child has just turned 13 so we're trying
to talk to her and tell her not to be so
open and friendly with everybody
grandchildren is the byproduct and it's
just a wonderful wonderful thing it's a
different time man
it really is it's so weird when your
kids are having kids is it it really is
it's better had I known how good it was
gonna be I would have tried to why
couldn't I was gonna say I would have
done that first but I did you can't have
more kids
no had grandchildren straight to Train
children yes oh wow
that would be amazing but I love having
grandchildren is my is my lifeblood now
yeah I like that
yes but my kids are old my kids are
adults my kids are working and doing
well and that makes me happy yeah
now do the grandkids think that you are
it'd do great the grandkids think you're
pretty cool what are they how do they
behave toward you they love me and they
think I'm cool it's my kids that don't
think I'm cool yeah you know it's really
weird cuz I always say I always assumed
you know my kids were born and I was
already in this but when might when my
first daughter Jackie who has a Jaclyn
Schultz life with Jackie she has her own
YouTube and twitch I've been on it
before yes yeah she was born when I was
already on a series so I always thought
in my mind that if I was the child of
somebody who was on TV or was touring or
was a comedian I thought it would be
cool but what I learned to realize is
when you were born into it mm-hmm that's
just what it is and everything else is
cool so everything else was cool button
me oh I see what you're saying it's like
so yeah whatever you're born it just
seems like from the outsider's
perspective oh that would be the cool
way to be right but like she would
say as a little girl she would say you
know the cars on the freeway you know
Josh's dad sells those cars right I go
but I do comedy
I know but Josh's dad sells those cars
you know so she's when you grow up and
do it just like you you tell me about
your life and it's no big deal you told
me all about gay chicken and stuff yeah
and I think that those are fascinating
stories but to you that was just
Thursday yeah that was as regular times
yes but but to you it sounds interesting
because it's different your world seems
different yeah you growing up in your
world with 50 hamsters in your truck I
think that's amazing now you're not
married or have kids but you would think
that they would think it was cool if
their dad was driving around with well
if you had 51 hamsters yeah that's a
rebel but but I would imagine if they
were born into that it would be no big
deal in HAMP's people call him HAMP's
these days - really that was a slang
term yeah cuz sometimes you're in a
hurry lot of time to say hamsters you
know and you sold them in concerts yeah
we saw him outside of Hall & Oates
you've heard of that band yeah yeah
Daryl Hall and John Oates yeah why why
would the small notes it would this is
so eclectic sublime in Holland Isle
gerald levert or Eddie Levert and I hate
to say it I love the LA verts music but
I don't some of them have passed away
and so I don't know which one it was
this is a hamsters or no levert Zillah
verts the hamsters of will pass away in
how long does they have what is a
lifespan of a hamster Oh a good one
an honest one I would say probably I
give any hamster ballpark now I'd say
we're going 11 months overall if you
average out all the hamsters and they're
late they don't even live a year I would
say at the rate that people don't take
care of them yes I would say
statistically a hamster lives 11 months
across the board of all time
but a good hamster one that you take
care of one you love when you keep you
know near water hydrated you know you
taught Yuri massages back they get hip
dysplasia
so you massage its back and stuff
sometimes oh I think could be with you
for nine years maybe they get hip
dysplasia because you're stamping hall &
oates or look
you shouldn't be putting bad in the back
different times and hamsters were wild
wild animals were when you were growing
up I know but I don't understand going
to a concert I bought a t-shirt at a
Chrysler
I bought a beer at a con so k-tec never
guess where I was last night
look at my hamster you know yes Lola
notes oh I didn't know you liked Holly
notes well look at her I bought two
hamster yeah I got that ariana grande
double ham brother that's different
times you know we used to sell hamsters
G pigs and then when people what is the
difference between a g pig and a hamp I
feel like okay well ham very small
hamsters are not as friendly let's pull
up a picture of each one if you don't
mind Nick wait wait wait wait how do you
tell what do you mean a hamster hamsters
not friendly no but a G pig is friendly
oh yeah and when you and you're looking
at a rodent okay they're there what
makes like there's the guinea pig in the
hamster and which one is the vs. you
have them in the picture versing each
other they do yeah that's a contest
somebody does online can you give me a
better picture of a guinea pig just by
itself solamente what if I bought and
these are dining they eat them in
somewhere Peru no they don't
yeah look at that beautiful animal right
there so is that friendly or not Fred
like how do you know whether one's
friend that is friendly guinea pigs are
very friendly and they get nerve I can't
they're like this between the guinea pig
in the hamster I don't understand the
difference I think bigger beautiful
bigger you know that you look like that
they look like a traveling buddy they
like it they could survive a storm
hamster look very have you ever been in
a storm with a guinea pig oh yeah and we
grew up in lightning storms all kinds of
stuff like that
and you find during storm season that
there that a lot of the hamsters are
dying and guinea pigs are living through
the storm so that would you say oh it's
the other way around
no hamsters are I mean they're higher
off the ground is a flood they're gonna
be able to withstand that first inch
hasn't even hit their nose but a
hamsters you put a hamster in an inch of
water man it's a wrap
so would you be able to predict weather
or how bad weather is based on the
survival of uh I couldn't somebody could
if you see hamster scurrying away rains
coming yeah like if all your hamsters
how to get to a high area if they try to
get on the top of
and he'll then that means rains coming
you know so when they say scattered
showers mm-hmm the scattering is really
they're referring to the showers a hands
the hamsters the showers is the rain the
scattering is the hamsters leaving the
area yet to make way for the weather wow
this is I had no idea and I thought I
was doing your product test but this is
like being on a real of like a weird
segment of Animal Planet oh it's like a
really bad nature show
scattered showers also probably I'm sure
you know it seems like a jerk like
something you would have in like that
kind of in the germaphobe world people
will talk about scattered showers well
so what a homeless person goes through
yeah scattered showers not all the time
just it's scattered I showered in
February and I'm gonna do something and
I'm gonna wash up right now yeah that's
my biggest fear of you know I my heart
goes out to homeless people and I do
when I pass somebody I'll give them cash
man soap oh really that's a good idea
yes I could see that if you would have
done it if you could if there's a
different business cuz you work in a lot
of different businesses you know
stand-up you know show development
production you know I know that you also
do like you know some real estate stuff
here and there like I'd like to be
proactive I am you always are I am and
what is another job like something maybe
you would have done if you had more time
I like to I like creative I like being
creative I'm doing things now I've tried
it's not gonna happen but I uh you know
what I'm doing now I like board games
and what I was doing that I do
I like monopoly and I took a lot of that
I'm taking it's not I don't know that
it's gonna catch on but you know little
houses that you have in monopoly yeah
the red and green one yeah reading green
ones you have the green ones are the
homes yeah I glue those to I not glue
like permanently but I I stuck them to
my testicles oh really like around the
back of the testicles to around the
front of the testicles because I'm
trying to create my own cul-de-sac
oh my god that's ridiculous
why just because it is man it's gotta be
you just hear yourself say that's all
aside which is friends I like that it's
French do you um would you ever be
French eating would I ever be French
yeah well you know I'm Canadian so that
is our second language I grew up you
didn't have a French ship on the deep
wow yeah which means I speak a little
bit I do and I have a business in Canada
and it's half of it is French really you
know I bought you know this I buy one of
the partners in jfl and right yeah
that's just relax right and just for
laughs the head office is in Montreal
Canada I'm taking calls now the lines
are open this is my wife Teri
I'm with I can't talk to you now because
I'm with Theo von she loves you I heard
that she said your hamster and guinea
pig stuff is her favorite comedies oh
she's my face well what about my the
thing that I do with Beaton oh no she
hung up on me okay all right
were you ever in love before your wife
like even as a kid was it like another
girl that you were mm-hmm cuz you you
and your wife got married right before
my wife I went out this is like a full
circle what it's identical twins no way
well a an identical twin I didn't take
them both out but I pretended I did I
always I think like each night I was
with somebody else but it was really the
same one but I knew she was a twin so in
my mind I was like a real mover yeah Oh
which one are you tonight
she'd get mad at me and broke up with me
and then I met Terry and I've been
married to Terry ever since yes I went
out with other people before Terry yeah
I did it's not like I don't know what
you're asking but it was an arranged
marriage no no no it wasn't in Canada we
do things similar to they do the way
they do it in the United States
yeah Erica yes you can meet somebody and
on your own make a decision and I'm air
this woman married us I talked about it
in my act people say are you 40 years 40
years to the same woman mm-hmm and I
tell them no well the girl I married was
like this young party crazy
oh I've imaginary yeah and I'll tell you
that today yeah not the same way change
how does it how does a marriage change
really over time like what are some
things that really kind of change about
it like what's that like
it's just noisier it's the same and it's
noisier and the noises don't come out of
you like when we were young there were a
lot of noises but it was usually having
fun when those noises were happening now
it's just like sitting and getting up
are probably the noisiest you would
think that's the beauty of a podcast you
got it that you should play a game show
is it sex or did he just sit down oh
right is he having sex no he's sitting
yeah he's sitting he moved to jostle
chair he's really enjoying himself do
you um actually speaking of a game show
we could probably go into some of these
games show videos that came in or sure
we wanted to we you know everyone knows
that you are one of the judges on
America's Got Talent
well I don't know that everyone knows
that but a lot of people millions
probably millions a lot of different
types of people to Philippines is also
one of those biggest fan ships is in the
Philip they are you want to know the
truth is I so I'm also on Deal or No
Deal which I'm hosting Wednesday nights
on CNBC but Deal or No Deal is a huge
was when it first appeared from 2005 to
2009 and the Philippines was one of our
biggest audiences in fact I went there
and played it know when Manila really
yes and did you use instead of
briefcases did you use you know
go ahead manila envelopes I wasn't that
good but it was good no but listen yeah
but I could have it wasn't good who is
this girl with the guitar this is a wee
one we have a couple of talents that you
want me to judge
is it okay I would love to judge her
okay okay yeah and we don't want this to
be on the payroll we do not want to pay
you the disa no we can't afford that
no I do this I judge I don't judge for
money I judge for just I think I'm doing
my I'm doing the world yeah okay I think
that everything I do
career-wise çetin brings us one step
toward one more step toward world peace
I love that that's why I do it that's
why I'm here I could see that I feel
it's good look at you brought two
candles together like hey look somebody
had to man let's sit let's sit let's
here so she just sent the still of her
playing guitar now how do you how do I
judge this does he look like you can
play okay look she's about to her name's
Kelsey Hopkins Kelsey Hopkins Kelsey
you have somebody else here first
I saw it
it was a lie to come a things then make
sounds the rest I can live without
Wow Wow I'm just judged mentally you're
the judge I love hearing a woman saying
man yeah do you like that yeah yeah you
thought that was good okay I think it's
a guy's got that kind of Halsey raspy
kind of grace Vanderwall which was my
golden buzzer she's very good it's just
I would like to see a little more rain
yes
can I see a little more range yeah no
because that's all she said
right it was just a them one tone but I
need to see yeah you know what I mean
she's got to take it up one level or did
you stop it before there was any range
she that was all she sent yes all she
said
not enough what's her name again Kelsey
- Kelsey you're very talented
I just think as an audition you need to
show me a little bit of you know like a
like grace Vander Waal in Halsey with
that raspy kind of whispery you want to
find you want to like a find what would
be that what would you call that moment
when she goes to that next level that
here that a hitchhiker that a hitchhiker
I don't know where that well you know
what real hot oh sorry
whatever just rascal later escalator oh
my god yes when I was a kid don't say
escalator I have a bad I was there's a
power failure once that I was trapped on
an escalator for over two hours
really yeah well that's it happens to
people still I'm sure I don't know but I
started getting claustrophobic
Laurel they called what where were you
on in between one two but they sent
people who walked up and assured me it
was okay to walk down and I was out is
this another talent that I'm about to
look at I've got a couple more talents a
lily he looks kind of look at that look
that's like a mug shot it's like I get
the doctor's office this time I might be
moms who ripped off my ears oh I know
you did you ripped my ears off okay go
ahead this is from Johnny book
leaving the name and our listeners can't
see but he took his tongue and touched
the bottom of his nose then brought it
up the other out of the corner of his
mouth that was nostril and he put stuck
his tongue into his nose yeah okay so
first of all while I was watching it I
didn't realize that was a talent I
thought he was preparing to do something
okay you know before I do this I gotta
lick my nose and I know how to clean out
oh yeah there he is again so there's a
reenactment for you Hal we won this is a
kid who grew up where his parents said
don't don't pick your nose I won't I'll
just lick it out I don't want to get any
snot on my finger I'll just take it
directly with my tongue I'll just jam my
tongue up my nose but that's cutting out
the middleman in a business sense you
got to respect that a little I do but
what I didn't love about it is he did it
and then his final word was sorry yeah
if your if your talent needs an apology
yeah I'm just saying you might want to
rethink it yeah you should reconsider
that I think another thing you could do
is I would love to see somebody who
doesn't pick their nose at all and just
shakes their head until boogers fall out
of their nose that's the old-fashioned
that well that happens in dry climates
yeah
that's but where where there is humidity
and moisture that'll never happen yeah
so that would have to be something
that's two pieces so you have a
whispering singer and a tongue nose
picker and then we have the oh this is
intriguing already I'm intrigued there
for those that can't see what I'm seeing
there seems to be some sort of Ottoman
with a rose and a shoe on it and this is
from Cindy Mae I hope it's not from that
same guy thirty-eight
it says 38 oh it's a birthday cake Howie
oh that's a cake mm-hmm she's turning 38
that was it that that's it so did she
receive it that she maketh a net that
stiletto is edible I can eat you can eat
her shoe all right well whoever am i
judging the person that made the cake am
i judging the person who makes yeah was
I that was it okay anybody ever done
that in your show me that is bring out
and leaving they go off safely pass
their talent there has been a lot of
things that have been somewhat
questionable and I like that you know
I'm fascinated by people by humans who
believe you know it's really interesting
that you know sometimes what's going on
in our own heads is not the same as
what's going on on the outside to
everybody else and that is most evident
if you go to a club mostly with men
watching men dance yeah because in their
mind you know this is going great
everybody's looking at me wait till she
gets a load of me
and I don't know that like there's no
mirror around but in his mind it's
really going good and in my mind I'm
going you may want to you may want to
stand still you may want to have it go
differently yes was there a time period
where men were good dangerous do you
think did you ever know I'm not into
dancing you know I judge dancing right I
don't really understand dancing I always
have a thought that maybe there are you
know I believe there is life outside of
this planet oh yeah and I would imagine
that they're wondering how come when
certain sounds are made that we're
calling music we move that we all of a
sudden like there's a that we get this
kind of weird kind of shaking and moving
and I would imagine they're studying us
and dancing is the most confusing thing
to people from other planet oh yeah dude
if I heard like I see a sound and then
see that go off maybe but then I guess
what if you whistled and a turtle just
the right paw came out of the shell and
fluttered like you'd go well it's not
that what is that what happens when that
sound is made what is that yeah and
that's what it probably looks like to
beings from other places like that yeah
like were their nature channel kind of
like they watch us like that but to that
end I always found dancing funny and
when I used to date before I was married
I thought it was funny to be the most I
was a big Jerry Lewis fan and I thought
like really funny dancing was funny and
I used to go to a club and ask strangers
like strange women would you like to
dance and then I would just rip a hole
in that dance floor the most obvious
that
the most horrible is announcing dancing
asinine dancing and you know they would
be but some of them would just walk off
but a lot many times they would just
turn their back to me to try to pretend
they weren't with me but that would
never stop me I would come around to the
front to make sure that everybody knew
that this is my dancing princess and I
just found that so funny it was awkward
and embarrassing and funny but I'm not a
dancer I watch Dancing with the Stars
and even when you are an excellent
dancer and I'm talking about the pros
and I'm talking about the male's
yeah it makes me laugh yeah I don't know
why it makes me laugh when I see people
ballroom dancing right it just makes me
laugh there are positions and poses that
I don't think we should do as I you know
like you I too are on the road and we'll
stay in hotels and they'll have like
sometimes in the hotel I'll have a
ballroom dancing competition yeah and I
go don't wait I have seen those and that
a polka one time too yeah and it's just
I could sit there for hours and watch
people dance it just makes me laugh I
would love to see you judge like a dog
show did you ever do one of those things
were you judged like or got opportun I
don't understand I watched a dog show
and I watched the Westminster Dog Show
yes it makes me you know and Christopher
Guest is one of my favorite directors
and Best in Show yes that movie is
really because I find that world and
what makes me laugh at the dog show is
are the dog walkers you know those
people that go out and they kind of
prance alongside a dog holding the leash
and then they tap it on the side and do
that and lift the chin yeah this and
check out and then lift the tail and
look at that shake its tongue I just
think that yeah humans I think that
that's what happened we should have
exactly what happens at a dog show we
should do that show for human yeah I
love that yes my son this is my annuals
and yes look at her pet him on the back
lift his nose look at his chin look at
his form watch how I answer yes that's a
suppository you've been a good boy and
that's it wouldn't be great because I
don't really know what they're looking
at and I don't know how you compare you
know a chihuahua to a Great Dane yeah
look at the Bichons cleft palate and
you're like what is that that's insane
but I love John O'Hurley he
the guy you know he's he does it well
he's the guy that does the the
announcing he's from Seinfeld remember
that he's got the he talks like Ted
Knight you know he's very like can we
see that do you know who he is the guy
with the gray hair he also hosted family
feud I think before Steve Harvey and he
talks like that that's his normal tone
Don and O'Hurley he does the Westminster
Dog Show and I think he's very serious
but there is but have you heard him oh
yes your Peterman yes he was mr.
Peterman but he is very serious and
notice the gait of that dog and it's got
quite a coat on it that the yellow I'll
say the hamster the Westminster hamster
so you know that'd be a funny video we
should do a video of like Westminster
but just hamsters and do it the same way
and have people walk can you put a leash
on Iams
um in some state I think you have to
have it on a leash in California if it's
outdoors we should do a giant like
really serious rodent rodent show yeah
odd now it's down to our final two the
squirrel yeah is up against the guinea
pig can we have the squirrel in the ring
one more time our judges are looking at
the squirrel oh and that's girl drop the
nut did you see that how he just left it
right right there that is not a nut oh
my goodness that let's pan away from
that all right um Wow and look if you I
don't know if I've ever seen this before
look at the perk in the earlobes of that
little Muppet fantastic I don't know if
it plays as good on a podcast as it will
on video yeah but we should do it we
should have been actually doing a little
video that we'll get to rodents and do
the Westminster run and get somebody
just added a rodent over a previously
existing there's a group called bleach
media that does that kind of stuff oh we
just take the the verbage from the
Westminster Dog Show and put so let's
not do anything let's just give out
ideas and somebody's probably editing it
now mark out YouTube yeah
has there been an idea that you had over
the years how I know you're an idea man
with that like you had like when I was
young I wrote a letter to the people
that had Where's Waldo
remember the books yeah so I wrote a
letter to them and I was like hey I want
to dress up like Waldo and just walk
across America and people will just be
like holy smokes
I saw Waldo somewhere and then that
would leave people to go and buy you
guys his books and we'll make a
real-life Where's Waldo book right and
they never wrote me back so did you ever
have any unless you have the address the
right address yeah I went and they get
where's the Where's Waldo people this it
was owned by some British people and
this is probably 25 years ago is owned
by some British people I bet most of the
world if you really want to look it up
and then and I in and I never got a
message back but I thought it was a fun
idea I bet you didn't find the Where's
Waldo people oh I bet they would have
done I bet you they what did they answer
you in any way
they didn't he's right there British
though they are or you looked it up they
didn't that's Where's Wally well same
guess what they caught of you know Liz
Wally you know and we're gonna dress
like that in the striped shirt and the
the Hat the winter hat yeah and just
walking over here hair like that yeah
and just walk across the country I think
the idea of Where's Waldo
is to be totally surrounded by large
groups yeah I'll go to layers and stuff
I was gonna go to Renaissance Fairs you
know if there's ever a fire in a
building everybody goes outside I was
gonna go there I was gonna go why
wouldn't you do it anyway anyway like
what here's my point my point is they
would sell the books you'd get no
benefit from that right why did you need
them like why don't you do that because
I where's Theo right why wouldn't you do
it I just I don't know I thought it
would be like a fun thing and then they
would be excited about it was a good
idea why don't you do it I don't need it
anymore
really I'm older yeah I want to walk
around out there it's loud by the
interstate like I was young my ears
could take that kind of heat you know
that sound heat but I can't take it now
I would do that
I'll get you I'm gonna buy you a red and
white stripes
yes
and I'm going to do some googling and
find out where crowds are and I will
drive you well you can use my uber app
okay and I will drive you to various
crowds and your friend here
what's your name which your first Nick
Nick can take pictures from above like
in the book yeah and people have to find
out where where's Theo where's Theo
where's the I think it would be good not
anybody even looking for Waldo anymore I
think well there's a new book out those
that my nephew's got a called where's my
it's where's Michael Jackson actually
and I'm not joking bring it up please
and my nephew's got it for Christmas so
it was a kind of crazy because anyone if
you were sitting there now Michael Jack
I'm like kids kids be looking for
Michael Jackson really yeah he can't
find it he'll find it
he found it where now Michael Jackson
well you can't find them this is just uh
oh there it is serious where's Michael
Jack that's exactly the exact book and
that is hysterical how old are the kids
that this was botfly nephews five a
night you know he likes to dance he's
got that Billy Elliot kind of vibe and
he's but yeah we zoom in on one of those
pictures Nicholas so we can see it oh
and you have to find it's like Where's
Waldo yep yes but you have to find
Michael Jackson he's in different places
he's in like a where's that a child
abuse center and then the other one he's
at a pigment factory different places
Westlake studio look at that they really
did put real place
oh yeah you know what's funny is I bet
you're probably in these books and where
there's all the celebs are all Allstars
are in it what are you talking about oh
the other people are known people in the
picture yep a lot of them are is that me
the bald guy in the middle you see the
guy with the dinner who go go keep going
there yeah is that me that's not you you
found me I think that's me I think
that's how he is that is that tear you
next to you in the blue shirt I don't
know who that is but I think that's me
at the beat at dinner I'm at the beaded
dinner yeah dude that's so weird
well found myself I love that and it
reminds me speaking of the beat at
dinner imagine that time you got invited
to perform at that orgy
up in the hills remember that I did you
want me to tell you that um I've talked
about it we've talked about it before
yeah we don't need to talk what again
well I gotta let you guys know that
Europeans are really clean in their junk
area and that's because they've long
used bidets to cleanse themselves after
using the restroom while the bushwa have
used dry ineffective toilet paper and
never truly been clean until now but
delegates maybe get that hitter right
here and that's that fancy boot aisle
and front tile for the ladies and men
cleanser but d'Elegance natural
cleansing foam brings you the luxury and
elegance of a bidet with the convenience
of toilet paper you get that depth at
pay that you know that paper those
sheets and you hit that bend elegance
with it and tighten your area feel fresh
feel new
you can clean and dry your private areas
front and back better than dry toilet
paper and wet wipes it's more cost
effective and anti-inflammatory soothing
keeps your hands dry does not harm sewer
systems and eco-friendly support our
small business this is our small
business for this episode be d'Elegance
maybe admin elegance it's available
right now on Amazon for 10% off and free
shipping use promo code 1 0 th EO vo n
that's 10 Theo von 1-0 Theo von
for 10% off and free shipping used 10
Theo von at amazon.com but delegates get
that cleanse I want to talk about what
can we talk about that's fun I love this
I love that this is such an honest oh my
gosh it's totally it's just like I just
no but I love you very rarely listen to
these podcasts where the guest is here
and the host is here and the house goes
mm-hmm how can we talk about yeah let me
think of something fun let me you know
it's weird because I was on Twitter
yesterday and you were saying
any questions what do you want me to ask
College what do you want me if you have
anything that you're interested in about
Howie Mandel send it that way because
he's on my podcast tomorrow and Here I
am five ten minutes into your podcast
number one there hasn't been one
question from a lunar so nobody sent you
anything wait wait wait wait wait wait
and not only that you didn't preparing
No so you are sitting there five minutes
in going god what can we what can we
talk about I don't know I don't know
nobody had any ideas nobody's interested
we showed you a picture of my netbook I
did that I had two viewers I have that
one we could show that guy that picks
his nose with his tongue we did that
he's got him in the the singer that
wasn't that exciting though she may be
talented but not a good choice in in he
could have given a bigger buffet of her
talent you got the guy who picks his
nose actually had a second Talent he did
yeah
oh so then I'm wrong there was a
plethora of things and we have the same
guy what's this he's pulling his neck
he's pulling the skin on his neck and
then Wow that's it well he does the
other side I don't know if that's Talent
but I think it is no I don't think it is
he said I don't know if it's Talent but
I think it is to be able to scan off his
face a little you're doing it too many
of their talent he just pulls the skin
on his face he cool play in the face
skill yeah um I used to do that with my
testicles did you really well you know
what I did with my testicles we when I
was a kid we didn't have no I'll tell
you one let's match stories okay okay I
my friend had silly putty mm-hmm and if
you took silly putty and you're stuck in
on the comic strips did you ever do that
it can make the picture off of that yeah
I didn't have silly putty but on a hot
night I would sit on the comics with and
push my yes onto the and I had for a
week I had Beetle Bailey not press it
onto anything else yet I can see your
Dagwood beat that what did you do with
your nuts oh dude I remember this man I
remember
there was one point when I didn't think
that it we needed our nuts I thought our
nuts were you know like the appendix of
our body you know of our wiener and you
woke up thinking I don't need this
well it seems so silly it really does
well your wiener has urine coming out of
it and you know and you can't although
why all the time no I mean I you know I
tie it off at night but uh but a lot of
the time and I knew I was like well man
this is you know useful piece but then
you got these nuts you're like oh well
this is something we use back in the day
you know we're primates or when we're
dice you know just had people with just
using them so you were trying to
expedite don't need this what do you
call it when think morph when things
change on evolution evolution you were
trying to train so that you don't wind
up body part when they don't have that
third finger anymore oh uh it's called
mutate and not me yes transmutation no
something like that anyway you were
trying to okay you in your mind there
was no use and you wanted to move us
along go ahead so that was it so I
remember talking to some people at
school and being like you know I want to
give my nuts away to some place that
could use a mortar like I sent them to a
country where people can use them where
people still use them because I thought
people that were more primitive than us
like third world countries and tribes
yeah like oh there because it's always
the higher echelon of educated people
that are aware that they don't need
their nuts and they should mail them to
other places yeah those that's the yeah
that's the chosen race look I've thought
about nuts to have you yeah I talked
about how you know and depending on what
you believe but if you believe that we
were created by God mm-hmm that this is
an amazing art form right the body
oh and especially the female body and if
you look at the female body you know and
and if you go to Europe and you see the
great paintings in the Sistine Chapel
it's like the body is an amazing art
piece brilliant you know in the ribs
dude ribs are wild okay so anyway the
but I was thinking that that just an end
the ability to you know this is the most
important you know that God made earth
and made the animals and the hamsters
and and and alkanes yeah yeah so and
then and then but I was thinking like
you know and then on the seventh day he
rested man and woman our bodies are art
pieces and even the I I think that the
female body is artistic yeah I feel like
he
they say that we were created first and
then from our rib a woman was I don't I
think it's the other way around
we look like he gave up yeah I think he
gave up I think he made this amazing
body and even gave us the penis and
that's the plug that fits into the
recharger so that there's more humans
yeah but then it was like and then he
finished and he went you need something
else but I don't have time and I don't
have energy and I feel like our nuts are
that to go back yeah yeah you know I'll
take those to go and out of all the
beauty he created these two little nuts
in a you know like Anna crinkled up sat
yeah it's just like with all the beauty
that has been been created throughout
the world I don't know why this is such
an ugly piece of business it is huh it
is and that's why I understand you as a
young man thinking we don't need this
yeah I love the lighting in this place
it looks like an extracurricular yeah
it's like we don't need our nut we just
lost one I don't know we did something
happen yeah lighting burnout oh my god
so people who are listening to this at
home or in their car they don't know
know but they don't know that we're
doing this in the dark candles now that
would be a new Howie show doing this in
the dark why is it my show and not yours
just because it seemed like something
you would try to you know like I know I
would never do things are here I want to
see what's touching me and what I'm
touching I don't know why I don't want
you would get other people hey do you
want to do this in the dark that's what
you would do to them I feel like I'm in
the dark most of the time anyway do you
I do I feel like things are going on and
I'm not part of it is that true that is
absolutely good actually understand that
yeah that freaks me out I spend most of
my time like freaked out there's
something going on and I don't
no and they're not telling me and I'm
not invited and I want to be involved
yeah and then there's there's the whole
world and then there's me yeah I feel
very alone do you feel an infection
sometimes really they're like I want to
be involved like what is the thing that
keeps you like have you been able to
kind of pinpoint what that thing is that
make that keeps you like wanting to be
in like yeah fear I'm always afraid that
I'm left out and going to be left out
and I try really hard to be a part of it
I want to be a part of I never feel like
I'm a part of it right I feel like even
like I listen to this and I feel like
I've loved this podcast and I love you
and everything I just feel like this is
probably the one of the two I'll be
totally honest this is probably one of
the least interesting episodes really
cuz I'm on it well I'm not interested in
anything that I'm talking about
no because but even the fact that you
know I thought that like you tweeted
nobody sent nobody sent the question we
know that you got you and is ten minutes
in you can't even think of anything to
ask me I don't think I'm that
interesting I don't think I'm and I
don't think people care but that's okay
no I'll just keep trying hard and you
know it's paid off I realize like if I
look and stand back I've been able to
buy a house and pay the rent and buy you
socks so but the thing is that it's
working for me yeah but I still feel and
it always was like an outsider you know
as a kid in high school I was in in high
school I was four foot nine and eighty
ninety ohms
yeah but how oh in high school Wow yeah
no that's a lower guy when I yeah well
you are I don't know what the heights
were back then I mean it's like the
heights are the same as they are now
heights is height but anyway height
hasn't changed well probably know do you
think I am but what if the law when I
was a kid everybody was nobody was more
than five feet tall when I was a child I
thought the whole NBA was five foot two
height was the same I was a little guy I
was a little guy he wanted a little I
felt little I felt like such an outsider
I looked up at the whole world
I wanted to meet girls I couldn't have
girls tall girls huh if you were a girl
you were just tall yes I was so little
so you know I just wanted somebody to go
up on III couldn't meet them and I found
weird wait I wanted I figured sports was
a way in though where what sport could I
be either I could see you playing no I
didn't make the soccer team didn't make
the football team didn't make anything
so the one thing that I found without
thinking about it was wrestling oh I got
in the wrestling did you really I did
because there's an under 90 pound weight
class in high school like this is for me
no that's why they hired me then I think
okay I'll just say I'm on the team I
didn't think about the ramifications
around racial men or women men so that
was the thing I wanted to meet women and
now I'm wearing a singlet which is just
like a one-piece girl's bathing suit and
I'm rolling around on a mat with another
guy this is not the best path no I'm
dressed like a girl and I'm wrestling
other me I don't want to touch anybody
now I'm rolling around with another
sweaty guy
we're just sweating together oh yeah and
he would pin me and then what that's it
well then we went out for dinner and it
goes on let's get into a couple of those
questions Nick that came in but you want
to show him a picture of me he Nick's
got a picture of me does he really yeah
so my hair was really long too and your
voice didn't change and I didn't shave I
look like a little girl one way I tried
to meet girls was by going into the
girls bathroom and brushing my hair in
front of the mirror oh that's kind of
cool so that they would talk to me they
didn't know I was a guy okay they passed
that bro he's I think Nick is getting a
picture of me
yeah and he'll put it in will edit it in
so that um so that we can see it one of
these questions uh let's see here
Oh question came in lots of them whoa
mini Ollie and it's hard to have a plan
with you I feel like because you're like
no I don't need a plan all here's a
question isn't this the same girl - hi
my name is Alisa
um actually read something funny about
Howie a while back that you had youth it
was like a prank in high school
you kicked out think you tried to hire a
construction company to do something I
was just wondering if you wanted to
explain that a little bit because I have
explained it I can only tell you that
inks thank you I think you Alyssa
you're a pretty girl yeah I'm very
pretty um yeah I hired a company I um
I didn't have friends and I didn't have
but I loved like candid camera but I I
forgot that you know that's a guy with a
television show who had an audience and
had a reason right I didn't have an
audience I didn't have a reason so I
would do you worse at school but I would
do these fucked-up things for my own
like it would be great if you were my
friend and I said Theo watch this with
three o'clock look out the window
there's gonna be a guy measuring with a
clipboard and he's gonna be putting he's
measuring because he's a construction
company I called it good wait till you
see the guy I didn't tell anybody so I'm
alone in the room looking at the guy I
called out there and then I see the
principal go out and I could see them
just stick you letting you know just
they're talking and I know that that guy
he the principal's saying what are you
doing in the yard and he's saying I got
a call from a Howard Mandel and I'm
gonna give a bid on the addition to the
library and then I saw him walk in then
I hear over the PA system when Howard
Mendel please come to the office and I
went to the office and he said did you
hire somebody to put an addition onto
the library and I said very emphatically
no no I'm getting a bid and he said wait
right here and I waited and they called
my parents my parents came and remember
my parents just sitting there and he had
to be in blast of it my mom was biting
her lip because he said you know your
son is getting bids on an addition to
the Learning Resources Center and as if
she was going to say we told him never
to do that yeah you know she was biting
her lip like I don't know what to do but
it was deemed that I had a penchant for
development what I had behavioral
problems so I was asked I don't have a
GED really no do they have that in
Canada what do you guys get they have
high school yeah yeah we have high
school and TV
we have cars we have warm meals when I
was growing up they had no joke in our
classroom it showed America then they
had a picture of Mexico and it was like
a cactus and a man with a beer yeah and
then Canada it had a boy in a scope
getting chased by a wolf and that was
the whole is that where you were gonna
mail your testicle that was can you
imagine being up in Canada and then you
get like what are these things Hestia
cause I got the mail snacking on a pair
of man eggs I could would you ever do
you think if you're stuck in a snowstorm
what part of your body do you eat or
your friends body do you think and be
honest man
please okay I will be honest I would not
lie okay if I'm stuck in a snowstorm
what part of my body do i e or a person
somebody else's Oh like the rain that
went down yeah right so you have to eat
people you gotta eat something you gotta
eat I would probably this would be the
process would be the problem I would eat
myself yeah I would eat myself I
wouldn't want I don't shake hands right
so it's like I would eat myself and I
would Tim oh my [ __ ] that that won't
kill me I would start with my I just
need my let I would have been like I was
just the like so item local buy just
whatever I couldn't reach and I would
just take bites out of myself yeah I
would eat myself would you I would
because be honest and I don't know this
I think I'm tasty yeah I do I feel like
I feel like a nice trap I feel like I'm
tasty I feel like sometimes I look in
the mirror and I go delicious I do
because and nobody else looks delicious
to me I could see it let's take another
question that came in yeah yeah what up
the oh yeah a hoop from Minnesota Gang
Gang how he is when you're on Deal or No
Deal did you or the models know which
case had what money you so did you know
where the million dollars was that no I
love that he asked the question player
okay um no nobody knows nobody no nobody
know be honest though you seem like you
would know why cuz you know stuff I look
smart but I'm an idiot right no I don't
you on the show nobody knows and it's so
there was a remember that movie quiz
show there was
there was a yes that wasn't good move it
was so it's based on in the 50s I know
yes somebody cheated yes and ever since
that it's like you have no idea our show
and every other game show there's
something called standards and practices
and there's a third party they it is so
locked down we do even our executive
producer doesn't know where the million
dollars is so they have a another
company that comes in and they randomize
the cases they take all the cases and
they put the different amounts and they
close them and eat and then they pass
them out to the ladies and as the ladies
are making their way to the stage even
if they slip a little and and a latch
sit open but it doesn't open so you
don't know it we're shut down for
another hour where they take the cases
back and they reran them eyes Wow nobody
knows nobody knows where the money's at
no I didn't even know where the Dutchess
was I had no idea that Meghan Marco I
don't know if you know that yeah she was
on the first incarnation of Deal or No
Deal
and when you looked at her could you
tell that she was gonna be like a
princess yes yes she had something
special
she was Dutchess II yeah yeah and I
didn't know what that meant but I kept
saying well she seems what's with all
this Duchy eveness yeah like what the
[ __ ] is this like why would I look at
this girl do I hear like you know music
from Liverpool you know Beatle music or
something Dutchess E or something yeah I
didn't know what it was and now this new
one which airs Wednesdays at 9:00
o'clock on CNBC I don't think we have
another Dutchess but I think we have a
dictator really yeah who's up in the box
Oh who's on the show one of the ladies
no way yeah yeah she's hardcore I just
think that this she one day she's gonna
be running a country I'm not gonna
mention which one but I think if you
watch you'll see which one oh wow
and I'm curious I'll check it out and
yeah dude I remember when we worked
together man I was nervous about meeting
you
I was nervous about meeting you know I
wasn't there anymore yeah I wasn't I
didn't like me at first really yeah no
I'll be honest with you it's really hard
to make a TV show yeah and we produced
you to deal with it you host a
it and we were shooting it and I had a
partner Roy yep Roy bank and and I and
we were just getting it's just you have
no idea it's so much easier to be on a
TV show right then to make a TV show
yeah and be besides all the notes and
all the input and all the a lot of work
it's crazy and it was a lot of so I was
under a lot of pressure yeah and that
pressure kind of I think showed itself I
loved you from day one I actually loved
I wanted them and fought with the
network to say listen I knew that deal
with it was about for those that didn't
watch it or don't know you know people
were asked to do things in an earpiece
and it was like a hidden-camera show
yeah but I thought the gem of the show
was when a guest would sit down with you
yeah and you would just be you like what
you're doing now and start talking to
them and just to watch their faces where
if they didn't know this was serious or
they didn't realize they were on this
planet yeah you had a story for
absolutely everything and I would
continuously fight with the network
because I would send in I go this is
funnier than what we're making the
person do right stick cheese up their
nose yeah listen to Theo talk to this
young lady is so funny and it was but
doing a show is a constant fight yeah
Wow so you're never in you can't just
that's why I love stand up yeah because
stand up and and I continue to do
stand-up and have a special yeah my
first special in 20 years real time yeah
my first standard people don't even know
I'm a stand-up anymore young people have
just seen me on Deal or No Deal or a GT
and you know I have never stopped doing
stand-up but people don't but that's
what I love I love the autonomy of being
able to stand there and whatever happens
happens there's no add in there's no
marks to hit where and you get that
immediate response so must feel like a
freedom to you these days to have that
kind of time it's my primal scream so as
much as I I produce and we continue to
produce that's a constant fight and I
also think that creativity by community
is not great like right youth if you
want to be outrageous or something
happens you don't need 20 people with
notes to go that's outrageous but let's
try it like this and that's what I would
when you saw maybe a that was the vibe
that I just wasn't having as good a time
as I would like to have the best time I
ever have is doing stand-up yeah yeah I
can imagine now I can see that
especially in the beginning of the show
because it's just there's so many moving
parts or somebody you know I don't know
if you're aware but how many people were
sitting behind the scenes that you know
you would say something or we would do
something and then I'd walk back and get
a note from the network and I'd walk
back and get a note from somebody who
was advertising on our show and it's
like and then I'd have to be the bearer
of the information I didn't want to be
the principal yeah you know you want to
be oh they don't want to do it like that
you can't do it like this they want to
do it like that and that night I was so
nervous
nine out of ten of the notes we're not
mine but as the producer I have to take
responsibility and give them to you is
it hard to go from like being like the
talent what makes it what is it that
makes you want to go from being like the
talent where you get to be fun and have
the fun and then to go up to the next
parts of the producer is it is it that
youth like what makes like some acts
I'll tell you something I like it
because well I come as you alluded to in
the beginning of the this thing I come
from business yes and I thought it would
give me more control but the more you do
the less control the more you sell you
know you sell an idea and then you have
a network or putting in millions of
dollars and they give you know zillions
of notes millions of notes but I also
like the idea you know I'm this is the
dichotomy of the two things I like the
autonomy of stand-up comedy where I can
go and do anything and say anything
though you can't really these days yeah
just used to but I also like the idea of
having an idea and then lo and behold
within a month there's a hundred or 200
people on a set all doing whatever it
takes for them to put together that idea
and then you see your idea come to
fruition but that doesn't come without
its you know problems yeah
because more people no problems yeah
that's the truth more people more
problems huh yeah man it's interesting
because sometimes it's like is it better
to just kind of stay in the space where
you can just be funny and be the the
entertainer or is it like because it
does feel tempting I feeling like a lot
of comedians have this like we like I
mean I have like a control issue I do
want to control things you know well you
know and also it's also if you want to
do what you want to do then you're at
the mercy of everybody else to want to
give you a job right so if you can come
up with ideas creative ideas that aren't
necessarily just jokes or material that
you can use for stage if you could
create it like even you had an idea you
wanted to do a podcast right boom it
comes together and now you're sitting in
this palatial studio yeah with candles
of different scents and an entourage
that you're not even aware you have and
that's because you had an idea beyond
standup yeah whatever you did so in and
you can have another idea which takes
you know 200 people to do it right 12
cameras in a soundstage and whatever
it's also the need to work and to be
creative and have ideas instead of just
sitting at home and waiting for the
phone to ring because there's there's
millions of us out there that are
waiting for the phone to ring right you
know or you sit at home in your room
like the girl you just had on playing
guitar and wanting to hear how good it
is on a podcast you know she's got a
it's really hard to get out front and in
front of people you got to do it you've
got to do it and you got to do more than
just it yeah you got to do more than
just hit these days
you really do yeah I think the
difference between people who are
working and people who are not working
is you're working right that's the only
difference you creating your own stuff
they just did it right you know I had a
conversation with somebody you know
they'd go Elon Musk and you know the
pilot and the plane the only difference
between Elon Musk and anybody listening
to his he just did it right I mean he
doesn't you look at the the guy is
flying the plank he imagined that the
guy's a pilot well he did it he did he
was injured he or she was interested in
doing that and went to flight school and
they did it and and we're going that oh
it they're doing it right yeah if that's
what your desire is then go to flight
school and become a pilot
be flying a plane yeah if you want to be
a surgeon go to medical school work
really hard and you could be a sir
they're not different than you and me
yeah and the reason you have a podcast
is because you did it yeah
I didn't write I didn't one day I just
started in my kitchen and then yeah and
then next thing you know yeah we just
had a podcast but yes it is true I
remember how to I had this show idea
where I was having like strangers set me
up with a blind date in their city
whenever I got there to do stand-up for
the weekend right and it could be
anybody in a real blind date where I
would never see the person and I
remember like I went and did a couple of
them and it was gaining traction on my
Instagram this is about five years ago
and I remember talking to a manager
about it and they're like well let's
let's package it up and try to sell it
and then once I did that I wasn't doing
it anymore and so then it kind of lost
the steam it lost the excitement and I
said but the truth is that you are in
control of whatever you do right you're
saying it lost the steam right if I lost
right you'll I couldn't be HEPT it going
and then also try to go sell at the same
time or not right just keep it going and
it might have on its own snowballed into
something why not and that's what I'm
saying so sometimes you know in the a
living evolving point I live in the
moment you know whatever I'm doing right
now I'm doing right now and there's no
end game and that's what you were doing
you were doing something that was fun
and kind of outrageous and then there's
no real end game and then when somebody
gives you a goal and then you're working
toward a goal you're not having fun in
this moment yeah and that's the yeah
that's kind of true huh yeah I wish yeah
in hindsight I guess maybe that's the
moment where I learned whatever it is I
just need to keep doing it and and then
at least that way I'm creating and I'm
producing instead of like you know
stopping and like packaging it up yeah I
guess I'll loss I don't stop for a
minute but that's also because I'm you
know I've got mental health issues yeah
so I try to distract myself every minute
and I stay busy and be what I do to stay
busy seems to turn into like work work
you know and it would not work for the
things I like to do who are some of the
top five people you think with mental
health issues probably you and for other
people you're at the last mental health
dinner no I think the last so I think
that anybody alive has mental health
health issues oh yeah I think very few
people are able to identify it or
willing to identify it or there's a
stigma I think if you're human you have
a mental health issue yeah and if you
think you don't have a mental health
issue that's that's a mental thing as
your wife yeah yeah yeah but I there
isn't anything that happens there's
nobody in LA you know there's a t-shirt
that says [ __ ] happens and [ __ ] happens
to anybody and we all need help and
whether you're dealing with what I deal
with with anxiety or OCD or just you
know your own productive ability or your
own fears or loss or sickness or just
being able to be productive you know you
need coping skills and until that
becomes part of our curriculum will have
a [ __ ] up world yeah we do need to
have that more that in school don't we
like how we don't teach kids to like get
along with one another and teach them
like how to express their feelings and
recognize like if a friend is expressing
like fear or concern or those types of
things and we don't teach that and we
don't [ __ ] 90% of the stuff that you
learn I'm talking you're talking to a
guy with no GED but yeah is not useful
in your life oh dude they don't teach
anything that does juggling we had
juggling for a while I'm like what
school did you your honor kiss school no
that's cool local school regular school
to the juggling class in regulate had at
first some guy came in juggled or maybe
he was just I don't know he could have
been a substitute teacher talking about
being the class clown but do ya have a
look at our town yeah if the teacher was
if a teacher couldn't make it they just
put in the next most talented person to
come and teach so at this point it must
have been a juggler you know so to me
yeah you could get anything
that's so weird yeah it's a little thing
is that 99% of what you know I say this
you know I'm in real estate and I'm in
business and I say this ad nauseam to
everybody around me but it's fourth
grade math yeah once you have the math
fourth grade once you learn how to write
once you don't even have to not write
anymore but once you learn how to write
and you know how to add and subtract and
divide until you figure out exactly what
it is you want to do unless it says a
specific skill like a pilot or a surgeon
or an engineer you don't need any more
to get along in life but you do need
social skills which aren't
professionally taught you do need people
you know I
say this people take care of their
dental health they don't think here are
their mental health you know you brush
your teeth every day and everybody goes
for a check-up and says look mom no
cavities but nobody
there's rest your brain right you gotta
and nobody is sitting there all this
[ __ ] that's going on in our world in
these mass shootings and things like
that there were red flags years and
years ahead and these could have been
identified in five and six-year-olds
yeah and they worked boy this got
serious that's okay
this podcast is kind of see I mean this
podcast is really pretty just serious
it's never it's something really it's
never really even funny
never I don't know if it is is it it's
got a good mix of both yeah and all the
conversations they go in waves and
that's what people like yeah it goes in
waves that's what people like the most
on our on our podcast is just kind of
regular just chatter do wom looks at
let's pull in another question then that
came in for Howie what's goofy Oh was
good Howie there's one no and then
[ __ ] out there who broke your home
let me know who broke your heart feel
how I Mendel I said break him on right
now they break him on right now okay I
don't know who that is
he's heartbroken that's full is he
heartbroken he's sitting in his bed at
night with a comforter he didn't even
turn on the light [ __ ] question the
depression no I don't know that seemed
pretty healthy to me man and look how he
was playing that Dutch oven game too
it's kind of covered himself with his
blanket but he was building a tent how
are me both Dutch oven annotate because
he can only jerk off to the smell of his
odd now that's an old-fashioned treasure
that's an old that's definitely an old
school trick who broke my heart man I
remember the first girl I ever loved was
his girl named Chrissy hunt she had a
chipped tooth that I'd never seen that
on a woman before Wow and now sexy oh
yeah was it in her mouth or he just
carried it around what I got I got a
chipped - oh well that would have been
beautiful I got my heart broken a lot I
get my heart broke yeah right whoo man
who was she and nobody liked me I was I
told you I was four foot nine
it was like I know that little guy bra
no I would not on you do that [ __ ]
put you a foot in a sweat suit and just
[ __ ] hug you I would how we know I
would I just lived with a broken heart
and even now I gotta tell you and with
social media my heart gets broken each
and every day really yeah I can't stop
reading it I can't stop taking in the
pain yeah but people are mean they don't
like me they turn me off my heart is
well I've talked about this many times
but even at the height of my notoriety
in the 80s I'm in my mid 60's now oh
really yeah oh my god you seem so
ageless man really mmm wait to hear the
noise I make when I get up from this
thing but yeah sex yeah I don't know but
he the point was that you know I played
Radio City Music Hall Wow in one day we
sold out two shows in one night that
pretty exciting well here's that here's
the thing so seven I think it holds like
six seven thousand people so between the
shows I was out looking at like 7th
Avenue or whatever it is in New York my
wife was there and there was 7,000
people walking out of the building as
7,000 people were lined up to come in
and and the cops in the middle of
Manhattan in New York City where there
were stanchions and there they were
helping traffic flow and all these
people were coming out in middle of
Manhattan this you know this idiot kid
from Toronto is looking out the window
from backstage at Radio City Music Hall
and my wife said to me isn't this
amazing
I don't know and she goes what do you
mean and this is truly how I feel I said
well we're in New York there's 10
million people in New York nine million
nine hundred and eighty five thousand
people in this town don't give a [ __ ] to
buy a ticket right right there's always
million so which breaks my heart you
just said yeah they don't like me
yeah fourteen thousand but fourteen
thousand out of a million people and you
know as a comedian and this is how it
feels for girls and and wherever
life and I've talked to every comedian
about this when you're on stage you
could be kicking ass and killing and you
see one person and you can feel where
they are right
ain't that weird yeah and it you're
drawn to the one person that's born this
is [ __ ] he he or she hates you
doesn't like what's going on yeah I said
why it doesn't matter that there's
thousands anything you're then almost
know right so I don't know why and
that's I know that he's asking about
romantic like who broke your heart but
that breaks my right that that
heartbreak is somewhere built into baked
into a comedian well it's it's baked
into all of us you know when you're in
love or you love somebody and they don't
love you back but your heart is broken
and it's rejection
mmm all it is is rejection you want to
be loved you want to be accepted as much
as you want that person and whether it's
in an audience whether it's just
somebody on Twitter
who's calling you a [ __ ] idiot or
you're pointing out you know physically
you know you're called yeah you know but
it's I get that it's funny and I know
intellectually that sometimes it's funny
but my heart gets broken every day every
minute and we have to we real and this
comes from tons of therapy nobody can
actually break your heart they can hurt
your heart
yeah but you can you know you have to be
you have to give yourself enough inner
strength and I think that's both of us
as comedians the the strength to get up
in front of strangers and try to be
accepted by people we don't know yeah is
what we fight every day against that
heartbreak yeah though I don't sit in a
dark room with a comforter asking
strangers questions I think he's got
bigger problem I mean I like he might
have they need to pay his electric bill
to that's it look a little bit alarming
like you couldn't even turn on the light
for a question what a real beautiful
heartbroken because the electric company
look at this guy let's play one more
year for how we do how we premature Nick
what's up gentlemen I hope y'all are
doing alright this is Oliver from North
Carolina
what's he probably I was wondering
before no you know the shiny look you
have to learn up there what was your
hair history
and our history it's kind of a weird
phrase hair industry but uh yeah tell us
a story about when you had hair and what
that was like what do you miss about the
hair do you miss anything tell us a
story about when you had hair and what
was that like what it what kind of stood
there it is
oh well it's um you were Howie did you
kind of look a little bit like Melissa
via senior can we bring a picture of her
ah I do in this picture and I and both
you guys are very talented voice-over
artist as well you know why I look like
a young guy I look like you should put
up the picture that it's online Nick
well put up Melissa first but then yeah
I do yeah that's pretty cool can we get
another word look at my more I don't
have a hair story
oh right there no up right though right
bit left left one more left to the idea
that looks like that's a little emo ish
but I can see yeah that's a little emo
Philips yeah the haircut but that but
the thing about I look like the kid from
stranger things put up the picture of me
is Howie Mandel and what's that kid's
name
bas Rutten no Howie Mandel and ginger
things kid and they have a picture of me
at 16 and I look exactly like the kid
Wow
there's there's usually two pictures of
me together online
Howie Howie with hair and stranger
things maybe is the thing to look at do
you have it
is it coming up Howie with hair and the
stranger things guy they come up there's
a split screen usually together Howie
with hair and the stranger things guy no
let's gonna keep going keep going no no
no it is that guy right there in the
middle but there's an exact picture of
me find it online oh the boy wait keep
going keep going down that picture there
in the middle in the middle and the kid
from stranger things Wow
find the kid from stranger things so
that's me at about 15 oh my god bro were
you something happen look I so he left
you somewhere where was that taken
what
what are you seeing that I don't see
that it looks like like I was left
someplace
were you like left it lets seem like you
were like Robert Plant or something or
um not that Who am I thinking of you
look like uh but um um oh okay a little
Rolling Stone I look like a little girl
I'm a little girl on how we don't ever
say that you don't think that looks like
a little girl yeah a little
a pretty girl though thank you do you
think I'm pretty
I think you are actually I know I think
you have an a nice I think we've pointed
out today that I'm pretty and delicious
do you have the splits do you have the
split uh never mind this guy it doesn't
matter but that looks like the kid from
there's a kid from stranger things right
now that looks exactly like that yeah
there he is Finn I put Howie Mandel and
Finn I did and it didn't come up to both
of us yeah didn't oh but I look like
that kid right yeah wow look at that
Wow Wow
um we had a question much stranger thing
yeah man that's and that's very handsome
boy that was my hair story that your
friend asked for and then tell us a
story about when you had hair do you
miss it or not do you think it's coming
back no I don't miss it I'll be honest
with you I'm gonna get picked up for
another season no but I still I like to
like I like to do that to pretend I have
bangs I like to flip my head I don't
miss hair you know what you know it's
interesting when you don't have hair mhm
how much time I have now like how much
from that from the moment you get up in
the morning you don't realize how much
time you put into your hair oh yeah I
know you brush your teeth but you move
your you move your hair you don't want
to answer the door I don't have to touch
anything
yeah so I save a lot of time with
adjusting my hair I save a lot of money
there's no shampoo involved you know I
don't have to wash it it's good its Jen
and more importantly it's I was thinking
and you're you're inspiring me I was in
the 80s I had a mullet and I'm thinking
of growing back just the mullet oh I
think that would be beautiful just I'd
like the bald but I would like to have
just a mullet oh yeah because it's uh
well it you've brought back the mullet
you know what's funny is about two and a
half years ago I looked at a picture all
pictures of myself and I was like man
I've never had
long hair and I want to know what that's
like in my life I'd never had it right
except when I was really really young
but I don't remember that so I was like
well I'll grow it out and now I feel
more comfortable than I've ever felt in
my whole life
really yeah why like I don't feel like I
have hair it's like look at my hair it
just feels like it just feels like an
Express a natural expression of myself
and I've noticed a lot more men growing
Mane's you know there's a lot of long
that what you're calling it not a mom
not a mullet yeah it's just kind of lost
not a mullet no I think a mullet you
have to like well in Canada it's like a
hockey haircut like they are there more
it's like hockey players kind of have
them mullets they call them mullets well
it's like seriously serious in the front
party in the back right I'm worried
about going out of business in the front
and still partying in the back that's
what you want to do that skullet oh and
that's that beautiful gala but if you
drew a skullet bro you get free fish
anywhere where I'm from for probably for
life I'm gonna do it I'm gonna do it and
I'm gonna do it not because I like to
look I'm gonna do it for the fish Oh
tilapia oh so you gonna stop your breath
you could have as much tilapias you
wanted man everywhere you go people fill
your mouth with the fish room for a
skullet oh I see a skullet
yeah people don't mean a skill it no no
I'm talking about going out of business
in the front but still partying that
we're closed because it's a party in the
back no business nothing's going on no
there's rot in the back and a full party
in it but now you've got it happening I
like your hairstyle um let's talk real
quick about the Comedy Store yeah do you
was the time when you were coming up at
the Comedy Store do you look back on
that as one of the best parts of your
career do you look at like what do you
look like as an educational part did you
look you look at that as a time when you
made most of your friendships or was it
friends but I'll tell you come head it
if I just kind of give me this some of
that I don't think the Comedy Store will
ever be like it was and I still work
there and I still love it yeah and
that's where I write but that was the
epicenter of everything and I mean
everything you know I I'm of the belief
that you know in the early 70s or late
sick
these rock-and-roll was everything you
know Woodstock it was where the youth
got its you know political lilt it's
where it got its fashion from it's where
you know peace love and rock and roll oh
yeah and then you know rock and roll
started dying out and disco became big
but disco was kind of there wasn't any
real substance I don't think it really
spoke to you know the studio 54 and
right the drug but guys like dancing and
drugs but it didn't really but I'm
friends with this guy Rick Newman who
opened up catch a rising star and Mitzi
got the Comedy Store going and The
Improv going and and comedy just
exploded as the voice of the youth and
everything we watched on television so
when you looked at people like Freddie
Prinze who blew up and it was the first
time you know a Hispanic lana
a sitcom right and Johnny Carson was
pulling all the great young comics from
the Comedy Store and that's where they
were just exploding and getting their
own you know from Billy Crystal to Robin
Williams and I came out there and I
watched Richard Pryor each and every
night yeah work on his set to put
together for live on the Sunset Strip
people were lined up for three shows a
mile down Sunset Boulevard it was the
most exciting place on earth the biggest
movie stars in the world we're showing
up you know just to see the next young
comic or the Richard Pryor's that
doesn't exist anymore I mean it's fun
and it's entertaining and there's a lot
of good people but you felt like you
were on this new exciting Wain of what
became you know and then sit that's
where all your sitcoms were cast out of
that's where all the monologues were
made and the movies and then people who
were filling in for the hosts of shows
Joan Rivers would come there and Rodney
Dangerfield would come there and and
David Brenner would come there you know
they were filling in for Johnny Carson
and Johnny Carson you know it was a
comedian who would come there and work
out his act to take to Vegas and in the
main room that you'd have Count Basie
and his orchestra and Buddy Rich and up
in the belly room
the Comedy Store you I saw Whoopi
Goldberg as a young comic show up and
audition for Mike Nichols and Steven
Spielberg and eventually got cast from
that night in the color purple which
made her career you would watch people
just explode there and right now it's at
and I think now there's a resurgence but
that was the epicenter of everything
that was comedy and that was before I
mentioned earlier jfl now that's a place
where people can get seen of be seen as
now it's a jail called Toronto last year
actually it had a nice time I didn't own
it yet and you didn't not last year but
now now I do now we're talking now I'm
the boss no now oh I need to go next
year yeah yeah man it's different over
there now do you think that comedy will
ever be like the voice of the people
again or is it too sad a is it too
fenced in and governed to these days by
I feel like that was the epicenter and I
feel like the voice of the people now is
much more digital you know and whether
it's from podcasts or from YouTube or
from Instagram or wherever that's those
kind of lilt our you know our feelings
and and our thoughts and our pop culture
but that being said the art form of
stand-up comedy is alive and thriving at
the Comedy Store even today yeah agreed
yeah it's almost amazing sometimes like
the moments you can have in there you
know it's very there review very few
places that kind of and just by virtue
of what stand-up comedy is that kind of
draw in a lot of people of like mind who
have very who vary in their comedy
stylings so on any given night they
could see you and Joe Rogan and anybody
they see Alyssa via senior or me and and
you know you could see one after another
chris d'elia or you know all these
people obviously you see on television
on any given night it's all there and
that's a gathering place whereas I don't
know that there's a club for music where
you can go in and see
even more than one you'd be like BCBG
would be like something like that now or
something right over that nothing that
but but how many groups that you know or
listen to or stream or what can you see
in one building whereas stand-up comedy
this is a buffet of great art yeah
that's cool
Wow way to finish that off what what
just that that piece about that I don't
know how many store I think that's why
these guys are here this sounds like I
don't know if their selves like how's
this again it's just so weird that we're
doing we're multitasking because we're
doing a podcast hmm at the same time
we're part of a document yeah
are you aware of that oh it's the dark
arts man there's a lot of levels going
on I wonder if the people watching are
fascinated at watching a documentary
while there's a podcast go I think
that's the beauty commie study the
comedy story
it's just comedy yeah it's just stand-up
comedy this is the difference between
then when I went yeah saw one thing on
one place and now now it's oh now you're
watching this is about multi-touch but
even now this documentary right now
we're watching two comics right who are
at the Comedy Store to do comedy talking
about doing comedy on a podcast yeah in
the 70s you didn't watch you didn't have
that you never had the moment again you
have we lost the value of a moment a
little bit do you think because then
like now a moment is so it can be just
so
I don't know does that make any sense to
you have we lost the value of a moment
well here's what we lost you know I
believe I've been diagnosed with ADHD
yeah but I also think that our culture
promotes that and you know when we were
growing up I'm older than you but when
you watch TV you just watch TV when you
went to a club you watched a comedy a
comedian and now when you turn on TV in
the corner of the screen there's another
piece of information that usually has
nothing to do with the show you're
watching right there can be a strip
along the bottom with information going
through what you're reading the news or
the weather at the same time right I'm
you know you're getting all pieces of
and even when you buy a magazine I doubt
that that many people buy magazines
anymore you know you they'll finish the
story on page 86 which is so you can get
to start another story right and by the
same token we're doing a documentary and
a podcast at the same time so you talk
about the moment we're at a much in this
time in this millennium we're at a much
faster pace where more has to be going
on to hold somebody's attention for even
a moment I'd like to take a moment but
if you take a moment people will go away
yeah and do you think that that that
that do you think that will have side
effects from that of like like well I
think we do I think that's why you know
most of a lot of young people are on
ritalin yeah you know and because
they're trying to focus because it's
really hard to focus because it's hard
even if it's innate in who you are it's
also like you got the two candles with
two different scents well you talk about
a DD that limbo right now that's exactly
and in a painting of yourself or leave
it
well that's Chris Farley yeah I don't
know when they come in yeah that's Chris
Farley no now I see it yeah I didn't
because there's so many pictures of you
all around we're gonna wrap up in just a
second Kevin Farley his brother his text
to me yesterday actually and said hey
man I love the picture of my brother in
the studio which is really really nice
Brady are you giving me a signal I am
now I'm finished no you're gonna go on
forever man how long do you so I didn't
realize at first I felt bad because
there were you know because I saw their
outreach yesterday
input but I didn't realize that there
was gonna be like two people I know with
three talents and two questions I had no
idea no no and now that I've seen it all
together I know I realized there was so
much more than I could've ever expected
no it's great look our I mean our
listeners just like to kind of just you
know know what's going on and just just
hear what's up and well watch my
Showtime special listen to two people
taught are being on Showtime and when is
it starting January 18th and watch Deal
or No Deal
every Wednesday um was it nerve-racking
with the special cuz I saw you a lot
before that in the store like you were
in and out a lot it wasn't getting up on
stage a lot I was you know it was
nerve-racking and I did it at my own
Club I have my own Club in Atlantic City
do you really what is the Borgata it's
at the Hard Rock Oh called the Howie
Mandel comedy club is it really yeah
I don't know how we came up with the
name but I have an idea my mom thought
of it I didn't uh how was your mom good
yeah she's okay she's a cute lady I
remember you matter yeah she's doing
okay she's up in Canada oh yeah I've
heard of all that and what else did we
want to touch on I think we might have I
think we're done yeah I really do yeah
the the fact that we're done yet we're
still talking on recording it's just
uncomfortable I wonder if it's
uncomfortable as uncomfortable for the
listener as it is for us probably I
think they love it
really yeah but David in or whatever
they clicked on this podcast you know
with you talking to me and we've just
announced that it's over yeah I would
imagine some of them just turned off
whatever no instrument there this is
when they really turn it up really I
think so I think yet a lot of the people
that are listening to podcast
eavesdroppers people that would be
eavesdropping peeping tom kinda but they
know it's over it's over and it's just
awkward oh yeah dude it's been all I
don't know if like I'm because I I'm not
familiar like do you have a like a
wrap-up song or
it got noms Nick got fired from working
with Corolla you know I'm doing my best
I'm 30 about 40 days off of pornography
right now
and waiting only 40 days I talked to you
a year ago and you were off of it and
now and I got back on Wow and it didn't
go that great I mean it went fine you
know but it would it wasn't like
long-term you know what was the longest
you've been off of it is it 40 days
yeah maybe actually and is it like a a
like if you're off of pornography for a
lot like do you get I know that at a a
and a year you get a birthday party and
you'll get a you get a chip but when
you're off of pornography for a long
time what do you get a hard-on yeah dude
I was on a plane and I got a hard-on and
some lady brought me out of sleep I was
sleeping on a plane had an erection woke
me up told the flight attendant they're
like uh sir you need to watch your body
that's what she said
no is that serious yeah I got erection
in my sleep man but how you know the
truth is when you're sitting on a plane
you don't know you I feel uncomfortable
putting my elbow on the armrest so you
must that must be worse get my elbow
here but what I why don't you I would
have just taken a fence set yeah with
her oh [ __ ] you looking at and I even
told her husband I said this ain't for
you lady this ain't sure but this is a
you know nocturnal boner I had when I
was sleeping this I made this not for
you you know I'll let her know that this
was had nothing but the the flight
attendant came over to warn him give me
a little blanket a crazy as a pro for an
erection in my sleep man she give you a
little blanket tiny like a napkin I'm
one of those hot towels just a little
hot towel what that's so bizarre that's
the flight attendant what did she say to
the flight at the [ __ ] I'll admit it
was about so it's like you were waving a
white flag to surrender but but the
thing is that that's so bizarre that
there somebody would like even if it
happened yeah and even if the ego when
it did hit that sleeping guy look at
that sleep there's somebody to point it
out that's what I thought that's what I
and what she said she just like your
body sir you know and I was
excu and i don't know what was going on
i thought i'd peed myself in Sol's like
I'm sorry you know I didn't you know
this used to happen I was in my 20s but
this is you know not recently and then
I'm like oh man this is what's going on
had on sweats lean sweat pants and she
just got offended and she thinks she
told her husband and now that's why I
started looking at her husband like dude
tell your lady there you know or ask
your wife if maybe you guys can i'm
y'all haven't had a bone in the house in
a while or something you know it was
just awkward man and then it made me
feel bad like I was wrong for having an
erection you know so so that that's what
got you back on pornography or though oh
no that was probably did I mean you know
but now I noticed more erections and if
I'm on a plane I get an erection right
right you get that
no but I guess I didn't see the movies
that what snakes on the plane is no no
no I'm talking this irregular even just
dude if I even hear a loud playing go
bowels get strong you know really yeah
jumbo jets I mean oh and a jumbo jet I
call it baby a Puddle Jumper
look at my Cessna C will we ever see a
reboot of Bobby's world that was a
question that came in yes yeah I'm
working on it now I'm going to meetings
now I hope I come back I would love to
come back Wow we do too I told a lot of
people but you know that's the same
voice I got a it's the boppie voice is
other voice the gremlin voice yeah the
gizmo yeah oh man it's also Skeeter from
Muppet Babies yeah same voice dude I was
at a birthday party and I got cornered
by the guy who does Kermit from Muppet
Babies really yeah I got cornered
against him and he'd been drinking and
not actually and I'm still bummed
can I lean against a stove and started
up some pizza boxes on fire those at
Harlan Williams's house first Roy his
Christmas party was a fire there seems
to be a fire Thiel started a fire with
the pizza what are you leaning so back
it's so weird to see the permit guy and
Karma's flammable so he really was a
I see a lot that's the I don't know if
that's a good sermon but I just imagine
that's how the guy talks yeah I can't do
I can do uh okay Peter I don't know what
that one is
I think it's somebody who's looking for
something yeah I used to think it was so
funny to go onstage and I would have
these long drawn-out explanations this
next character I'm going to do is a man
by the name of Gary who works in a in a
packaging Factory who is late for work
because the bus hasn't shown up and we
go in today and it would just be a long
explanation till somebody in the
audience would go [ __ ] yourself for me
it was always funnier just happy just
the explanation just just nothing yeah I
would do it I do it an improv night I'd
go how a man they'll improv night where
I would just take suggestions my record
is 40 minutes no 40 minutes of taking so
not doing anything just okay give me an
occupation
give me a favorite color tell me give me
a state tell me what to say give me a
sense just how many until somebody goes
the [ __ ] is it yeah did you ever a
minute did you ever meet Andy Kaufman or
no what yes is the yes is the answer I
need to watch him and he was at the
Comedy Store in those days right and he
wrestling I'm sure was he so unique so
unique and I did evening at The Improv
with it I went to watch his taping where
he and that's on tape where he had a
boil on his neck and each person was
invited up from the audience to feel the
boil on his neck oh wow it's it's pretty
yeah I loved him and I loved that
commitment that he had yeah I could go
all the way it was the theater really in
my mind and Mike binder who is doing
this documentary oh yeah a director and
producer of this documentary and a great
comic in his own right do you know that
his connection Andy Kaufman do you know
so Andy Kaufman was on
taxi mm-hmm right player like taxi yeah
Mike binder was Andy Kaufman standin
would be there all week Andy Kaufman
would not come to the show until tape
night Wow
so all of it was done with Mike binder
really yes and do they look similar or
not not to me well maybe that in in
violet but it's really weird because
also Mike minder is said okay that he'd
like to do your podcast and I'm here
filling in as a stand-in until he gets
here he is Mike coming know what Mike's
not coming actually no oh well what
thanks for are we ending again yeah
we're gonna end again well what is the
record for ending a podcast like how
many times have you tried to get a guest
to go away
that's a good question probably three
times mm-hmm you know so it's been - one
more time and I'm out of here
he's like a genie why is that a genie I
don't know I just
Genie is the rubber bottle and then
makes three wishes yeah does this have
to do with that it doesn't just three
yeah just three just a bad reference
dude wow you guys are liking Oh
we're seeing oh there's bad sync over
here that's what I love that he gets you
and there was no even thought no
hesitation for three yeah three he said
three Jeannie did three wishes
I get Theo we want so well together it
is a man that's probably worked so well
together Howie Mandel thank you so much
for being here and thanks for always
being so friendly and supportive man you
always are and what was the question you
do a great job of that
thanks yeah this has been fun
[Music]
I must be
little town for me to sell that parking
brake and let myself on my
[Music]